♪
MARIA: WELCOME BACK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IS VISITING
THE CDC ON FRIDAY AS HE URGED
PEOPLE TO STAY CALM AS THE
CORONAVIRUS CONTINUES TO SPREAD.
P MY NEXT GUEST, GEORGIA
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS IS THE
RANKING MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR JOINING
US.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN ON YOUR VISIT
WITH THE PRESIDENT TO CDC, SIR?
>> WHAT WE LEARNED IS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS STILL ON TOP
OF THIS, THEY’RE STILL MOVING
FORWARD, AND I THINK THERE WERE
SOME INTERESTING THINGS LEARNED.
NUMBER ONE, I JUST HEARD THE
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK TALK ABOUT
EVERYBODY BEING TESTED.
MARIA, THE CDC MADE CLEAR
EVERYONE WHO NEEDS A TEST HAS A
TEST TO HAVE.
THIS IDEA THAT YOU NEED TO TEST
EVERYBODY IS NOT REALLY AN
APPLICABLE SITUATION WHEN YOU’RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU’RE
ISOLATING THE KNOWN CASES SO
THAT YOU CAN MAKE PROPER
TREATMENT, AND THAT WAS WHAT WAS
SAID, THAT EVERYONE WHO NEEDS
IT, ANY DOCTOR WHO NEEDS A TEST
CAN GET THAT TEST DONE, AND THAT
IS GOOD TO ISOLATE THE CASES TO
MAKE SURE WE’RE DOING A PROPER
RESPONSE.
MORE TEST KITS ARE COMING OUT,
SECRETARY AZAR STATED THERE’LL
BE A MILLION AND MORE IN THE
NEXT WEEKS, SO THOSE ARE GOING
TO BE THERE FOR EVERYBODY THAT
GOES FORWARD.
AND THE OTHER THING I THINK THE
PRESIDENT MADE CLEAR AND OTHERS
AT THE CDC WAS THAT THEY’VE BEEN
ON THIS SINCE DAY ONE.
THERE SEEMED TO BE THIS DELAYED
IMPORTANCE EVEN THE ABOVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS, BUT THE CDC FROM THE
MINUTE THEY FOUND OUT HAS BEGAN
THE PROCESS OF WORKING TOWARDS,
JUST AS THEY DO ANY NATURAL --
ANY NATURALLY OCCURRING VIRUS
LIKE THIS TO BEGIN THE PROCESS
OF WORKING TOWARDS.
I THINK THE REASSURANCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS AT CDC DOING AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE KNEW WE WERE ON TOP OF
THIS WAS THE BIGGEST THING
COMING OUT OF THAT THE OTHER
DAY.
MARIA: THAT’S TRUE, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME I KNOW THE CDC SENT
OUT 50 TEST KITS TO 50 STATES
AND SAID WAIT, YOU KNOW, DON’T
USE THE TESTS, THEY’RE DEFECTIVE
TESTS S. SO THERE WAS, THERE WAS
A MISTAKE THERE SOMEHOW.
WHY SEND OUT 50 STATES, THE TEST
KIT THAT THEY ACTUALLY WEREN’T
USABLE, AND SO WE DON’T REALLY
HAVE A CLEAR NUMBER IN TERMS OF
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE SICK BECAUSE
WE COULDN’T DO THE TESTING,
RIGHT?
>> WELL, NO, I THINK IT WAS
CORRECTED VERY QUICKLY.
MORE I -- HAVING A CLEAR NUMBER
OF HOW MANY PEOPLE IS HAVE THE
VIRUS, THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS
CDC, THERE ARE SOME THINGS WHO
MAY ACTUALLY HAVE THIS VIRUS AND
GET SICK BUT THEY DON’T GO TO
THE DOCTOR.
THERE’S A LOT OF THINGS IN
PROCESS, THAT’S WHY WE’RE MAKING
SURE THE MONEY WITH WE PASSED
THIS PAST WEEK AND THE PRESIDENT
SIGNEDDED IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS THE STATES, TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO NEED TO BE
QUARANTINED, NEED TO HAVE THE
MEDICAL TREATMENT TO HAVE
EVERYTHING THEY NEED, AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE DO THE
BASIC STUFF.
WASH YOUR HANDS, STAY OUT OF
CROWDS IF YOU’RE SICK.
IF YOU KNOW THERE’S GOING TO BE
A PROBLEM, MAKE SURE THAT YOU
TAKE THE PROPER PRECAUTIONS JUST
AS YOU DO WITH EVERY OTHER
THING.
AND I THINK THERE’S BEEN A
HEIGHTENED A AWARENESS OF THAT,
AND I THINK YOU’RE GOING TO SEE
THESE CASES CONTAINED, AND IF
THEY DO COME UP AS WE GO
FORWARD, WE’RE GOING TO HAVE A
GOOD RESPONSE BECAUSE THE
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE.
MARIA: WE’RE GOING TO SPEAK WITH
DR. CARSON IN A MOMENT, ON THE
WHITE HOUSE TASK FORCE, AND I
WANT TO ASK HIM ABOUT HOSPITALS
AND WHY THEY’RE PREPARING FOR
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE TO GO TO THE
HOSPITAL.
MILLIONS, I MEAN, THAT’S A
QUESTION FOR DR. CARSON COMING
UP.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU, CONGRESSMAN,
YOU’VE GOT A VERY IMPORTANT
DEADLINE ON MARCH 15TH, THE FISA
SURVEILLANCE TOOL, CERTAIN FISA
SURVEILLANCE TOOLS WILL EXPIRE.
DO YOU HAVE THE VOTES, DO YOU
BELIEVE, TO ACTUALLY EXPAND
THESE SURVEILLANCE TOOLS?
WHERE DOES THIS FISA
REAUTHORIZATION GO NEXT WEEK?
>> WELL, THAT’S A GREAT
QUESTION.
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE FOR A LONG
TIME.
THE FISA ISSUE IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO TAKE TIME NOW TO NOT
ONLY LOOK AT THESE EXTENSIONS --
AND REMEMBER, THERE’S TWO PARTS,
THE ACTUAL FISA PART THAT’S THE
COURT THAT WAS SET UP IN THE
’70s THAT IS IN PERMANENT LAW.
AND THEN YOU HAVE EXTRA PARTS
THAT CAME UP THROUGH THE PATRIOT
ACT LIKE THE LONE WOLF
PROVISION, ROVING WIRETAPS,
THOSE THINGS THAT DO COME UP IN
A SUNSET, SO WE HAVE TO APPROVE
THOSE.
MY POSITION AND I THINK THE
HOUSE’S POSITION AND I’M SURE
THE PRESIDENT’S MENTIONED THIS
AS WELL IS OUR TIME TO LOOK AT
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH THE
COURT ITSELF SO THAT WE DON’T
GET ANOTHER CARTER PAGE, WE
DON’T GET ANOTHER PRESIDENT LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS A CANDIDATE
AND AS PRESIDENT WAS ATTACKED BY
ROGUE CABALS AT THE DOJ ABUSING
THE FISA PROCESS.
WE’VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
OVER A YEAR AND A HALF, AND I
THINK THE HOUSE IS IN NO
POSITION TO PASS ANYTHING THAT
DOESN’T HAVE ACTUAL TITLE I
CHANGE SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT
AMERICAN CITIZENS IN SENSITIVE
AREAS.
I’VE BEEN WORKING ON THAT
THROUGH THE WEEKEND, WE’RE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT.
I REALLY WISH THAT THE SENATE
OVER THE PAST YEAR, HAD THEY
BEEN IN THE MAJORITY, HAD MORE
HEARINGS ON THIS BECAUSE FROM
THE MINORITY POSITION, WE’VE
BEEN WORKING HARD, AND NOW WE
NEED TO HELP THIS PRESIDENT AND
HELP ANY FUTURE PRESIDENT OR ANY
POLITICAL PERSON NOT HAVE THE
FISA COURT --
MARIA: IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU DON’T
HAVE THE VOTES NEXT WEEK.
>> NO, I DON’T THINK WE DO, AND
I THINK THAT’S A GOOD THING,
GOOD FOR THE PRESIDENT AND GOOD
FOR THE COUNTRY.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU AND I
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE LOST TRUST IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, IN THE FISA
COURT.
AND REMEMBER, THE FISA COURT WAS
PUT IN PLACE IN THE ’70s
BECAUSE OF ABUSES IN THE
INTELLIGENCE SYSTEM AND ABUSES
AMONG LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MARIA: RIGHT.
>> DOES THAT NOT SOUND FAMILIAR
TODAY?
WE NEED TO REEVALUATE NOW.
MORE YOU’RE RIGHT.
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT IT, AND
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT IT WITH
LINDSEY GRAHAM AS WELL, NOW HE’S
STARTED INTERVIEWS, I GUESS, BUT
IS IT TOO LITTLE TOO LATE?
I MEAN, ARE WE GOING TO ACTUALLY
GET ACCOUNTABILITY?
MY AUDIENCE WANTS
ACCOUNTABILITY, AND SO FAR WE
HAVEN’T SEEN MANY INTERVIEWS,
YOU KNOW, SUBPOENAS FROM LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
>> WELL, I’D LIKE TO SEE MORE,
AND I THINK THAT’S THE THING
WE’VE BEEN PUSHING FOR FOR THE
LAST YEAR.
IN THE HOUSE WE’VE BEEN THE TIP
OF THE SPEAR.
MARTHA: I --
MARIA: I KNOW.
>> I’M GLAD TO SEE THEY FINALLY
GOT STARTED, I’D LOVE TO SEE
MORE OF THAT.
IT WAS AMAZING THIS PAST WEEK
WHEN SENATOR RON JOHNSON WAS
ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO SOMETHING,
AND MITT ROMNEY ALL OF A SUDDEN
DECIDED HE WAS GOING TO POSSIBLY
OBJECT TO SUBPOENAS.
WE’VE GOT TO GET OVER THIS.
THIS IS AN ABUSE OF OUR SYSTEM,
AND IT’S AN INTEGRAL PARTICIPANT
OF WHAT THE DOJ DOES.
WHEN THEY ATTACKED PRESIDENT
TRUMP, THEN-CANDIDATE TRUMP AND
TRIED TO COVER IT UP AND USE
FISA, THERE’S NOBODY IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT COULD BE IMMUNE
FROM THIS TYPE OF ABUSE.
MARIA: I’M GLAD YOU MENTIONED
SENATOR JOHNSON, TALKING ABOUT
THAT WITH KEVIN McCARTHY
COMING UP, GOP LEADER.